first the game a hard-fought battle back
and forth no surprise ultimately you
fall short what did it come down to
well i thought love really made some big
buckets and you know obviously
we'd like to hit our free throws and uh
you know the
you know mark
uh
not being able you know he was never in
in the game and uh
our guys fought you know they're really
good
they're they're really good they're
they're experienced
and uh
they hit us with that onslaught of
threes and it looked like
we were gonna get grown out of the dome
and then our guys came back and
we got that one point lead and we fouled
on on and we did foul you know but you
got to play defense and make him shoot
the ball
and then
you got to you gotta put some free
throws in and
then put some game pressure on them but
uh congratulations to them yeah they
they've had uh
uh they played an outstanding game i
thought both teams played
play their hearts out and uh
it's an emotional win and it's an
emotional loss
and that's the way a game like this
should be
coach as you walked off the court for
the final time can you describe the
emotions that you were feeling
uh just for my players you know i'm i'm
i'll deal with me later
uh
you know
you know i
for me my entire time coaching i
always wanted at the end of the year or
whatever the last game is where
you're either crying for joy or you're
crying for sorrow
and if you are that means you've put
everything into it and
i have a bunch of kids who are crying
and i'm proud of them they've been a joy
to coach
and they've played winning basketball
and they did tonight too but uh so did
the other team
that's the final team that you're gonna
coach what was the final message to them
in there no just how proud them we love
them and the brotherhood that they've
developed i mean
they're double champions regular season
western regional champs 32 wins are you
kidding me
you know in this my final year
with this team they've been magnificent
i'm i'm so proud of them and i love them
and uh so it's you know right now it's
our responsibility to take care of them
and uh make sure that
they're okay they're you know they're
really down
you know and
especially younger players
will you know they'll they'll look at a
free throw and say i lost the game and
that's the other thing we
tried to look one play does not win or
lose the game don't beat yourself up
you know we we had our opportunities
they they made one more opportunity than
us
and uh but don't beat yourself up
because we wouldn't be here with without
them
you know they've all done really good
things to get us this far but uh
i love the fact that they feel that bad
and um and then
we just have to take care of them i know
i'm speaking for all of college
basketball but thank you thank you for
everything you've done yeah it's you
know um obviously i'll deal with all
that later but uh
this team's been a joy for me to coach
and
and especially
them turning it around in march
and to put us in a position where
you know we had a chance to play on
monday and that's that's the ultimate
goal
is to play on monday and have a chance
to win thanks so much